we got uh manipulative and gold digging
women why
are they a big mistake for men like why
is that such a big threat
well if you are somebody who is um
inexperienced and maybe you haven't had
a lot of ex
you know you haven't had a lot of sexual
partners you haven't had a lot of
girlfriends you haven't had a lot of
relationships
then you are particularly prone to this
kind of thing and it's
you know the thing about gold diggers
can get overstated at times i've seen
people on twitter saying things like you
know
you got you you're so worried about gold
diggers and you're owning 40
000 a year you know what what what the f
sort of thing and i
i can see that point of view i think i
think he gets a bit overstated guys
could be like oh my god is she a gold
digger
and i think i think actual gold diggers
who are
only after money i think it's a very
very small minority of
of women who who are really just so
cynical and it's just like i'm just in
this for the cash
but you can certainly get women who are
manipulative in terms of wanting to just
shape things to their own agenda and
this happened to me with a relationship
a couple of years ago i was with this
girl
and it was pretty clear that you know
she wanted to to get married she wanted
to have a family she wanted to
you know do do the whole thing and you
know i was being
primed for that position i i was just
the right guy
in in that place at the right time or so
she thought i then blew the relationship
up and got out of it
um but she was you know and it's not
that she was like an
evil person or that she was sitting
there with this big master plan
but she clearly wanted certain things
and you know i was a a homeowner i had a
property i think she quite liked that i
think that took one of her boxes because
she was like oh this guy's got some
some equity in london and he's got this
other place abroad and
you know there were certain things i was
taking some boxes and i think she wanted
things to go a certain way and
looking back on it now i could see that
her behavior was very
manipulative towards me and fortunately
for me i was able to sort of break out
of that relationship it wasn't
the easiest thing in the world but i was
able to get out of it because
i knew that i had abundance i knew that
i wouldn't just be you know just
sitting on my own three years later you
know crying about it sort of thing
well like like we know women generally
speaking are solipsistic right so they
have a difficult time seeing past their
own noses and they tend to
um make decisions and choices that are
more closely aligned with their own best
interests
you know like they're they're kind of
born with mental point of origin
hardwired into their yeah but what sort
of manipulation
would you uh suggest guys need to keep
their eyes open for
well i think anything that is
potentially going to
take you off your purpose really you
know it's kind of like because with this
particular girl
it was like i had certain things that i
wanted to do you know i was
working in a corporate job at the time
but i also wanted to do
writing i wanted to build my business on
the side you know i had
i had various different things that i
was working on and i was pretty busy i
mean i've always been a pretty busy sort
of
guy you know i've always been quite
driven and had various different things
going on
at a time and obviously a relationship
can conflict with that because they want
to take up a load of your time
but with this girl it was very clear
that
she just had different plans her plan
wasn't any of the stuff that i wanted to
do her plan was
right let's live together let's get
engaged let's have a kid and
probably move to some somewhere in the
suburbs and just do all of that
and so all of my stuff was just getting
bulldozed out the way
and it was very clear from very early on
so um
i think it's very it's very subtle isn't
it um
but for me the way i experienced it and
by the way this was only really the
second time i'd ever lived with a woman
and i only allowed it to continue for
six months because it was such a
nightmare
but it was it it was very
it's it's it's it's the death by a
thousand cuts thing isn't it
you know like she will first she'll say
oh don't go out on friday and see your
friends because i want to you know i
want to see you on friday and then it's
it's just
one little thing after another and it's
not like you can immediately point to
her and go you're being manipulative
she's sitting there like you know
cackling but it's just like when you
look at it on mass
you can see that there's a just this
build up of different things she's just
pushing your behavior so
i think it's anything that's threatening
to take you off the path that you had in
mind for yourself
is potentially manipulative and you've
got to look out for it
yeah that's a good point um i think that
manipulation
is something that kind of creeps up on
you i i've
i've been in a couple of relationships
um where
you start hearing nonsense like well
rich we don't do things that way or rich
that's not how
you know how it's done it's got to be
done like this yeah and
um you'll run into that with women from
time to time some are
some are worse than others others are
very you know
agreeable and in your frame but i think
that if you find yourself in a scenario
where
you know you feel like you're constantly
you know taking out a stamp and stamping
everything yes
yes yes yes you say honey yes just
stamping all that [ __ ] all day long
um you know given up your hope dreams
ambitions and desires
to placate towards all of hers all the
time you're definitely in something
that's a manipulative
relationship um as far as goal digging
um well women are hypergamous which
kind of implies that all women by nature
uh
would like to be with somebody higher up
on the socio-economic scale
yeah so i think you're gonna i mean
you're gonna have a hard time
not seeing that or some degree of that
but
there are a lot of women that are really
looking for financial resources
um acquisition of assets um
from guys you know they say that men are
hunters and women or
gatherers yeah hunt and acquire
resources
and monetary sort of rewards maybe
assets like homes lake houses boats cars
you know stuff like that
and women will tend to gather you know
bits and pieces of that from
you know the men that end up sometimes
in their lives so
you do have to be aware of that i mean
you do have to you know
draw a bit of a protective perimeter
boundary around you and your assets
and be very very careful about who you
let on
let in on on the inside because if
you're because if you're going to get
involved with a woman that really just
treats you like an atm
um and just sort of milks you for
advancing her own further agenda uh
you can't really create a train wreck
for yourself there's no doubt about it
yeah absolutely uh i think like you say
there's different degrees of it isn't
there because you've got the sort of
stereotypical almost like
ukrainian or russian girl who's just oh
buy me a handbag sort of thing and it's
this
there's that youtube channel is actually
dedicated to that i can't remember what
it's called but it's some chick that
like
sells it under the guise of um how to
date high value men
yeah basically a gold digger i mean
there's no way yeah i've seen that
channel actually because like when i
went on to beauty meets beast you know
that i don't know if you've seen that
a couple of the guys have been on to it
but uh they get they get a girl to
interview uh you know a guy in this
space i went on to that and they got me
for to prep for it they got me to watch
that channel and it is very sort of like
ah right and this is how you get him to
buy you a
you know i don't know he doesn't buy a
handbag then you have to shame him like
this right
yeah yeah yeah yeah entire strategy
about i'm not flying in coach but you've
got to fly in first class and if you
don't find me
fly me in first class and you're not a
man sort of thing right so
it follows through with either shaming
tactics or some pointing and sputtering
so you got to be good at identifying it
i mean
you can fly a woman either way you want
even if you have the financial resources
to put her in first class
at the end of the day it's up to you um
you know what it is that you want to
tolerate with uh gold digging and
manipulative type of behavior
um let's grab the super chat here real
quick so well there's two of them here
uh zdm314 says just wondering after last
ltr how did you deal
with the grief and loneliness of the
breakup fresh out of a 14-year
relationship and it's bad so he's
talking about grief and loneliness
well it's tough isn't it and 14 years is
a very long time so
i mean there is no easy answer to this i
don't think
other than you've just got to for a
start you've got to make that rock solid
commitment to yourself at the beginning
she is now effectively dead to me you
know
um there is no going back i'm and i'm
gonna delete all of her contact details
i'm not gonna i'm gonna delete her
social media
i'm not gonna look at her social media
i'm not gonna talk obviously i'm not
gonna talk to her but i'm not gonna talk
to any of her friends
i'm not gonna talk to anybody who knows
her i'm just going to make a complete
break because you need to have that
complete break from her
you know if you if you relapse on it at
all if you
take a peek at her instagram or
something it's just going to bring it
all flooding back right you've so you've
got to have that cold turkey
and then you've just got to have a very
structured ordered life you've got to be
like right okay so tomorrow i'm getting
up
at 6 a.m i'm going to go to the gym i'm
going to work for three hours i'm going
to do
xyz whatever it is and you've just got
to push through it and
i don't think that unfortunately there's
an easy way through this but you you've
just got to
you know you know you know the old
saying if you're going through hell keep
going
mm-hmm do you know what i mean it's like
you you've just got to keep that full of
momentum
you